pan la parole est à monsieur eric ciotti
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
berlin l'europe la civilisation des
libertés des lumières a été frappé une
nouvelle fois cette nuit de façon
tragique en cet instant après sept
minutes de silence que nous venons
d'observer je veux exprimer au nom du
groupe des républicains
notre solidarité avec les berlinois avec
le peuple allemand avec les familles des
deux victimes décédées dans cette
tragédie avec les familles des 48
blessés oui l'europe a été touché au
coeur
la france l'a été le 14 juillet dernier
à nice dans des circonstances tragiques
mans similaires cet attentat nous
rappellent que la menace est maximale
cet attentat nous rappelle que les
démocraties sont une cible privilégiée
pour ces barbares qui ont décidé de
s'attaquer à la civilisation à la
liberté à la démocratie
alors oui nous devons apporter une
réponse unanime
monsieur le premier ministre le ministre
de l'intérieur a indiqué ce matin ou ir
soir que le dispositif de sécurité
notamment à la veille de noël allait
être renforcée nous voulons avoir des
explications sur les moyens
supplémentaires que vous allez mettre en
oeuvre est ce à dire que certains moyens
ne l'était pas encore c'est une question
qui peut se poser est ce que vont-ils
engagée également une coopération
européenne nécessaire plus forte douanes
et le pnr notamment et enfin est-ce que
des contrôles supplémentaires vont être
mis en place à nos frontières pour
mesurer les risques qui peuvent être
associés aux flux migratoires
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la formule est un monsieur le premier
ministre bernard cazenave monsieur le
député eric ciotti
venez dans votre question de rappeler
les liens fraternels qui nous unissent à
l'allemagne et le devoir de solidarité
dans lequel nous sommes au moment où ce
grand pays ami et frappé à son tour par
le terrorisme pour avoir été avec le
président de la république et le premier
ministre manuel valls en première ligne
en 2015 lorsque notre pays a été frappé
puis en 2016 vous avez évoqué la
tragédie de nice je me souviens de des
mots des gestes de la chancelière angela
merkel et des mots des gestes de mon
homologue de l'époque thomas de maizière
qui à son tour aujourd'hui est en
première ligne et à ce moment là il y a
eu l'amitié franco allemande
la fraternité et la solidarité et comme
vous comme l'ensemble des parlementaires
qui sont dans cet hémicycle
j'ai aujourd'hui une pensée solidaire
une pensée pleine de compassion pour les
berlinois pour les allemands qui sont
durement frappés et qui à leur tour ont
vu le terrorisme tentaient de semer sur
leur sol
l'effroi mais cette solidarité cette
force de la relation entre nos deux pays
a aussi une signification
c'est un message que nous envoyons aux
terroristes qui est la volonté de nos
deux pays et de l'europe tout entière de
demeurer debout forte d'elle-même de ses
valeurs face à ceux qui veulent semer
partout la terreur par une violence
abjecte et je partage tout à fait votre
sentiment celui exprimé par le président
de l'assemblée nationale
à l'instant qu'il faut à chaque fois que
les terroristes s'en prennent aux
valeurs d'humanité d'humanisme qui sont
celles de l'europe répondre avec la plus
grande fermeté la plus grande
détermination et la plus grande
solidarité cela veut dire des choses
très concrètes pour ce qui concerne
notre pays depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois nous avons considérablement
rehaussé les moyens de la lutte
antiterroriste plusieurs lois
antiterroristes ont été votées et je
veux rentrer d'ailleurs hommage à
l'ensemble des groupes de la
représentation nationale qui pour
protéger nos concitoyens ont accepté de
s'ériger delà des contingences au dessus
des contingences de la politique dans
ses dimensions classiques pour faire en
sorte que nous nous rassemblions pour la
protection des français
nous avons voté ensemble interdiction de
sortie du territoire nous avons voté
ensemble blocages administratifs des
sites qui appelle et provoque au
terrorisme nous avons voté ensemble la
nouvelle incrimination pénale
d'entreprises individuelles terroristes
nous avons voté ensemble les textes de
l'état d'urgence et encore il ya de cela
quelques jours avons obtenu un vote
conforme des deux assemblées pour que la
protection des français puissent être
peu renforcé se poursuivre
nous avons fait le bilan ensemble et je
salue le président rebours pour le
travail qui a été accompli pour que sous
le contrôle du parlement les mesures de
police administrative les perquisitions
administratives les assignations à
résidence permettent de protéger notre
pays contre le terrorisme
nous avons engagé avec thomas de
maizière dans le cas d'un agenda franco
allemand pour la sécurité des chantiers
absolument essentiel pour la sécurité de
l'union européenne
renforcement aux contrôles aux
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne réforme du système
d'information schengen modification de
l'article 16-2 du code frontière
schengen pour pouvoir procéder à un
meilleur contrôle des entrées sur le
territoire de l'union
mise en place en france du contrôle aux
frontières depuis le 13 novembre 2015
l'interconnexion des fichiers
antiterroriste mise en place d'une
nouvelle directive de lutte contre le
trafic d'armes bref vous pouvez
constater à travers ce bilan qui n'est
pas exhaustif que nous n'avons cessé au
cours des derniers mois ensemble au sein
de l'union européenne de prendre les
mesures pour assurer la protection des
français
vous me posez la question de savoir si
on fait plus aujourd'hui qu'hier mais
nous faisons depuis des mois le maximum
est ce qu a dit bruno le roux hier et je
le remercie de l'avoir dit
de l'avoir fait c'est que dans le
contexte de menace des circulaires des
directives ont été adressées au préfet
rappelant les dispositifs que nous
mobilisons qui sont considérables c'est
une grande partie des forces de sécurité
intérieure des services de
renseignements qui sont mobilisés la
plupart des effectifs de la sécurité
publique près de 70 unités de forces
mobiles monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur une dizaine pour le contrôle
aux frontières le reste pour la lutte
antiterroriste
donc je veux que la représentation
nationale à travers elle les français
soient bien conscients que ce
gouvernement et avec lui ses partenaires
de l'union européenne
agiront de façon déterminée et avec la
plus grande fermeté et la plus grande
force sans trêve ni pause pour assurer
la lutte contre le terrorisme
parce que cette guerre contre le
terrorisme parce que nous portons des
valeurs universelles dans la cohésion de
l'europe et dans l'unité nationale ou la
gagnant merci monsieur le premier
ministre